j'étais un trafiquant de drogue j'étais un arnaqueur c'est
comme si je ne gaspillais pas mes grammes
je ne gaspillais pas mes grammes de sucre en poudre
ou de fromage à la crème
[Musique]
c'est ce que nous appelons des compétences transférables
transformez votre agitation
[Musique]
va devoir sortir par la porte, il
a dû sortir avec, donc le nom de
chef frais vient de
mon cousin, mon beau-cousin m'a donné ce
nom quand j'avais 16 ans, il vient d'un
film appelé Freshers sur un
jeune enfant  j'avais l'habitude de vendre de la drogue et de jouer aux
échecs et il était vraiment intelligent et sage
dans le jeu j'ai fini par devoir
travailler avec ce nom vous ne pouvez pas simplement vous
réveiller et vous appeler n'importe quoi
[Musique]
donc j'ai d'abord développé mon esprit d'entreprise  ce que
je considérais comme une
erreur de vente de stupéfiants illégaux
dans ma ville natale de pisco new york vendant de la
marijuana des choses de cette nature j'étais
assez bon dans les ventes et le marketing j'ai
assez réussi
dans le processus réel mais ce n'est pas
quelque chose que je glorifie tu sais mon  toute ma
carrière de trafiquant de drogue de 16 à 21 ans était à peu
près comme mon expérience universitaire
c'était comme aller à l'université c'était comme si l'
agitation culinaire était l'école des
coups durs pour moi alors ils m'ont appris
la vente et m'ont dit la gestion de l'argent ça
m'a appris l'ambition alors  ce super mode pour
moi pour l'entrepreneuriat qui n'est rien d'autre
que des hauts et des bas, des hauts et des bas, alors comme
je le dis,
transformez votre agitation si vous êtes coincé dans
un jeu de drogue, vous pouvez facilement passer
à la gestion de l'entreprise
et à l'entrepreneuriat
[Musique]
donc l'un des  les
principales idées fausses que je ressens quand il s'agit
d'aimer les anciens incarcérés étaient
qu'ils ne peuvent pas changer souvent,
ils sont toujours
aspirés dans leur environnement actuel, c'est
tout ce qu'ils savent que beaucoup d'entre nous peuvent changer
et je suis premier  exemple de cela
[Music]
des endroits comme le fonds doe m'ont vraiment aidé à me
structurer également était un
produit de programmes d'entrepreneurs comme
les cinq entreprises je n'ai pas
d'éducation formelle dans une école culinaire et tout le
reste est une pure passion et une expérience de travail
[Musique]
donc je suis sur le point de vous emmener les gars dans ma
cuisine fantôme où nous produisons
les produits nos gros produits délicieux
nous allons vous apporter un magasin
tout ce que nous faisons est fait frais à la commande
c'est à quel point ces choses sont jolies mec
c'est un vrai  caramel, vous pouvez littéralement
voir les odeurs sur le visage des gens quand
ils mangent les produits et ils
les consomment et à quel point tout le monde
devient heureux, vous savez
[Musique]
en ce moment, nous fabriquons la garniture au fromage à la crème
qui entre dans
nos célèbres biscuits au gâteau aux carottes ou
quelque chose comme notre velours rouge ou notre
velours bleu comme ceci est ceci est la clé
rien
rien c'est comme si je ne gaspillais pas mes
grammes
je ne gaspillais pas mes grammes de sucre en poudre
ou de fromage à la crème tout s'additionne vous
savez que
nous incorporons aussi l'amour  dans nos produits
comme ça, c'est littéralement comme l'
ingrédient numéro un
[Musique]
attendez mais la symphonie là-dedans vous n'entendez
aucun type de notes
d'appréciation
regardez ce visage
donc beaucoup de compétences que je
transmets encore aux patriarches de mon
opération de trafic de drogue  c'est comme le
service client, je dois toujours l'obtenir pour
le vendeur bas pour le haut nous achetons toujours du
matériel en gros j'utilise toujours des grammes
onces et des livres mesurant mes
kilogrammes de produit j'utilise une balance numérique
qui est super parallèle vous savez les gars
et je suis aussi dans la cuisine en train de le fouetter
comme de fouetter le produit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis que j'ai reçu mon cadeau qui est la
pâtisserie, je suis allé dans les écoles élémentaires les lycées les
collèges les cliniques du vih
les prisons juste pour être un  exemple et
partagez simplement mon message sur le fait que, comme
venir d'un milieu d'être
enfermé trois fois différentes, partir pour
faire du temps mais toujours pouvoir découvrir
ma passion aussi qui est la partie la plus
importante pas mal en cinq ans
de libération conditionnelle mon histoire  est juste le pouvoir des
secondes chances et juste comprendre
qu'avec le bon soutien et les
bonnes circonstances,
les personnes anciennement incarcérées peuvent changer leur
vie et réussir
vous